As with the previous video, I want to start with two "warm up" tasks.
And then I will continue with the lesson.
And you will make sure these tasks will be
slightly more complex than the equations in the previous video.
But we will continue to do exactly the same
operations, or permitted operations,
until we get the correct answer.
Here we have 3 times (x - 1) is equal to
2 times (x + 3).
Let's see what we can do here.
The first thing I would do (and here is not the only correct way,
there are several ways,
on which you can decide this equation),
but I would like to reveal the braces on both sides of the equation and multiply by 3 and 2.
So starting with 3 (x - 1) is totally the same as 3x - 3.
I just opened the braces and multiplied by 3 ... and this is equal to ...
reveal braces and multiply 2 on the other side of the equation.
2 times x plus 2 by 3, which is 6.
And now I want to put all constants
on one side of the equation and all unknown
on the other side of the equation.
Let's see if we can get rid of this 2x
on the right side of the equation.
Let's get 2h.
I'll use somewhat different recording this time,
because you can meet him recorded this way.
Or you may find it easier to imagine it that way.
Does not matter.
This is the same thing we did in the previous video.
But I want to get 2h on both sides of the equation.
If I pull out 2x on this side of the equation,
I have to pull out 2x on the other side of the equation.
So, if we take 2h on both sides of the equation,
what will we get?
Here we have 3x minus 2x.
This is only 1h or we get x minus 3.
When we draw 2x minus 2x, we leave x or zero.
And then we only have 6.
We get x minus 3 equals 6.
This happened when we got rid of 2x on the right side for the purpose
we took it out on both sides of the equation.
Now we have this -3 on the left side.
We do not need it for us.
I want to have only x there.
So, to get rid of it, we can add 3
on both sides of the equation.
Add 3 to both sides of the equation.
You can guess when we add 3
to both sides of this equation,
3 on the right side is equal to 3 on the left side.
As -2h was obviously -2x.
You can do it in both ways.
But if you add 3 to either side of the equation,
on the left we get just x because
these two are destroyed one another.
X equals ... 6 plus 3 equals 9.
And now we can check our answer.
3 times 9 minus 1 how much?
This is 3 by 8.
That's 24.
This is the value we get on the left side.
What will we get on the right side?
Two out of nine plus three.
This is 2 in 12, it is also equal to 24.
And so everything works properly. X equals 9.
The next task.
Z (div) divided by 16 is equal to 2 times (3z plus 1) divided by 9.
It seems quite complicated.
Let us multiply both sides of this equation by 9.
So, if we multiply both sides of the equation
9, what do we get?
We get 9 on 16 in z is equal to ... this 9 and this 9
will shorten one another ... 2 times 3z plus 1.
Now let's uncover the brackets and multiply it by this.
We will get 9 on 16 on Z equals ... 2 on 3z makes 6z, plus 2.
Now let's put all z on one side of the equation.
Let's get 6z on both sides of the equation.
Let's get 6z here, and of course,
we have to pull it out on the other side.
And what do we get?
On the left we have 9/16 minus 6.
What is here if we have 16 as a divisor?
Which number is equal to 6 if divided by 16?
Let's look at it separately.
60 plus 36.
is equal to 96/16.
So 9/16 minus 96/16, multiplied by z.
That's only 6, I converted it from -6.
is equal to ... these two are destroyed.
That's exactly why we decided to get 6z from the start.
And we will get equal to 2.
So, on the left, what is that equal?
Let me continue in orange.
9 minus 96.
Let's see.
The difference between 9 and 96 is 87.
And of course, if we get a bigger number
from less
we get a negative value, - 87 divided by 16 in z is equal to 2.
And we're about to end.
We only need to multiply the two parts of the equation
on the opposite of this factor.
So, multiply the two parts of the equation by a negative -16 / 87.
These shorten each other.
87 and 87, 16 and 16.
When we multiply two negative values, we get a positive value.
This is where we left with z, which is equal to 2 times that thing here.
So 2 times the 16 is negative 32/87
And we finished the task.
This is not a beautiful answer, but
that's what we got.
You can try other methods.
Maybe at first you will multiply both sides of the equation by 16.
Maybe you will uncover the braces and multiply by 2 and 9 first.
You can do many things.
You can also check that this answer is really true.
Now let's make a text task after we're hot.
All right.
The condition is: Manoy and Tomar argue about a focus with numbers.
Tomar tells Andrew to figure out a number.
Let's assume that the number Andrew has designed is x.
Make up a number.
Multiply it by 5.
That's what Tomar wants.
Tomar tells Andrew to invent a number and multiply it by 5.
Let's show it.
Multiply it by 5, subtract 3 of the result.
Let me use a different color.
I'll make it blue.
We get 3 of the result.
Here we get 3 of the result.
Manoeus is on.
This is Manoy.
Manoy tells Andrew once more
to figure out a number.
And so to think of a number again.
We will call it x.
Both make him figure out a number.
Add 5.
And now he says to add 5 to the number.
And we add it.
And then we multiply the score by 3.
We multiply the score by 3.
Andrew says that every time you apply this number,
receives the same answer.
What is the number Andrew has designed?
So, whether it multiplies the number by five and then exits 3,
or adds 5 and multiplies the 3,
he gets the same answer.
So what can mean that these two are the same.
He gets the same answer.
This means that these two parts are equal.
Let's solve this equation.
We get 5x minus 3 equals 3 x x 5.
This is a good start, we will uncover the braces and multiply by 3
and we get 3x plus 5.
Always remember to multiply by 3
all values ​​in brackets.
That's 15.
And, of course, 5x minus 3 equals that.
Now, I think you know what I want to do.
I want to move all the members containing x to one side of the equation.
Let's get them on the left side.
Which means getting rid of them on the right side.
So let's get 3h on both sides of the equation.
Minus 3x and minus 3x and what will we get?
Our equation becomes 5x minus 3x is equal to 2x ...
we still have minus 3 ... these two are being destroyed ...
is equal to 15.
Equal to this yellow 15 here.
Now we want to get rid of minus 3
on the left side.
And the best way to do it is to add 3
on both sides of the equation.
So we add 3 on both sides of the equation.
What do we get?
Now we have 2h ... and these are destroyed ... is equal to 18.
And then we divide the two sides into 2.
And we get x is equal to 18 divided by 2.
Equal to 9.
And in both cases, Andrew thought about the number 9.
Let's see if it works for Tomar's method
and Manoy.
If I multiply 5 by 9,
I get 45 minus 3.
We have 42.
That's when Tomar thinks.
When Manoy thinks - this is 9.
9 plus 5 is 14.
Thus, it becomes 14 and becomes 3 at 14.
3 times 14 and 30 plus 12, straight 42.
So Andrew was right.
When randomly chosen the number 9, and
whatever method he chooses, he gets the same result.
He gets 42.